good morning everyone and welcome to
this meeting of the development control
a committee my first of all reminds you
of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face mask
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or if you're exempt from
doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes that have been
provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off and your laptops
are switched to silent
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on
modern.gov.app
so please could members make sure
they're logged in and ready to use this
app confirm that's true thank you
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live onto
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via the fire exit
and make your way to the assembly point
which is ipswich town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire x6 at each end of the floor do not
enter the or
atrium ground floor area and walkways if
you are in the atrium at the time of the
of the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit use the stairs not the
lifts and do not enter or re-enter the
building until told it's safe to do so
and before we start with the actual
meetings it's appropriate to make some
introductions so down on my right we
have the area planning manager john
patron g
our legal advance advisor which is ian
de perez
case officers we have alex scott today
and marsa cavani we have governance
officer claire philpot on my right and
to my left alicia norman from the
democratic services and beth webb who's
a trainee governance officer um both
critical to making sure this runs
smoothly throughout the day we have ward
members today speaking they are
councillor helen geek and councillor
roland warboys and at mid suffolk
district council a ward member cannot
vote on applications in their vote in
their ward
there's a change to the agenda uh prior
to going to the agenda and that is that
we're going to do eight c first so be hc
followed by eight a and then eight b
if you prepare yourselves for that
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
do you have any thank you chair we have
apologies from councillor hicks and
councillor whitehead is substituting
thank you
i'm going to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-cuny interest by
members are there any to declare council
mayor
mr james bailey from eight a's and lives
in my ward and obviously we have had
dealings regarding paris council thank
you
declarations of lobbying
there are
yeah councillor even
um thank you chair stoneham um
email from stoneham parish council thank
you so much
okay so councilman councillor field as
well thank you
decorations of personal site visits if
any council mansell
when the um
stoneham
case came before committee before i had
to make my own personal site inspection
because i was unable to attend the
organized one by the council it was you
know a couple of years ago i i don't
think it's really that important but i
thought about it anyway they're always
right to state it thank you
and now we'll move on to uh confirmation
of the minutes of the meeting held on
assault on the 12th of january 2022
pages 8 to 13 of the agenda
[Applause]
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
in that case could have a proposal
please councillor passmore the secondary
council mansell
a government governance officer will now
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members if you go into
your mod gov app and select the cross in
the top right hand corner this boat is
now in progress
thank you members chair that's
seven votes four and one abstention as
council whitehead was not at that
previous meeting yeah thank you and uh
therefore the minutes are approved and
the minutes of the meeting have been
confirmed will be signed post this
meeting
we'll now move on to confirmations of
the minutes of the meeting held on the
9th of february at 2022 pages 15-28 are
there any points regarding accuracy of
these minutes
none i could have closed please
yeah councillor matthiasson and the day
councillor passmore
our governance officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair members again that vote
is now in progress
you won't check mine it's full
[Applause]
thank you chair as your vote is not
you're not able to take your vote no i'm
sure thank you so that's seven votes for
and again one extension thank you thank
you again the minutes are approved and
therefore they'll be signed at the end
of this meeting
so agenda point seven to receive
notification and petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
received chair thank you
uh we now move to the schedule planning
applications we're going to go initially
to 8 c and that's on page 243 of your
agenda council matterson
terribly sorry about this uh chair but
the
you weren't at the um the
february meeting so you shouldn't really
have okay yeah don't worry for it thank
you very much in that case i abstain
still carried and i'll sign at the end
of this meeting thank you for that point
really important
okay so we're going to move to 8c
now invite the case officer at marcia
caviani to introduce the application to
the committee marcia
good morning everyone
the application is in we can skith
move on to this slide
so this is the side which is to the
western side of grange road
and as you can see and there are some
residential dwellings to the opposite
side to the north of the site and
further south of the site
this is the wider context of the site
which is semi-rural countryside
this is the site outlines the red line
the boundary of the site
it's slightly further away from the
settlement boundary the brown
line here shows the existing settlement
boundary of wickham skeith
six semi um detached dwellings have been
proposed
the two in the middle are two bedroom
dwellings and these are three bedroom
dwellings
the access is approved um and it was
previously approved at
a previous approval which was for two
five bedroom dwellings
this is the elevation of the dwellings
as you can see it's traditional
conventional design
and of mother size
and the garages
so these are two bedroom dwellings
designs
a total floor area for these
are 85 square meters
and i have two bedrooms
this is a design of the three bedroom
dwellings and they are at 125 square
meters total floor area
and it is the garages the single bay
garages
again of similar style to the to the
houses
and these are some pictures of the site
which is kindly paddock
as you can see it's surrounded by trees
and hedgerows
the design includes the retention of
these
trees and hedgerows although none of
these features are protected
by tpo
and this is the view on grain road
from the south approaching the site
the speed limit is 30 miles per hour
and these are the houses opposite of the
application site as you can see there
are also semi-detached dwellings of
similar scale
the application site is included in the
new joint local plan however
a weight given to this is reduced
currently
as it's not an adopted document yet
however the allocation is for five
dwellings and here we have six dwellings
officer recommendation is approval
and i leave this to the member to decide
thank you very much if you have any
questions
thank you do you have any questions
please martha councillor eben
um thank you very much chair thank you
for that um
could you just um
explain for people living there how
there's i understand there's no
footpaths along the road at all so um
in order to get to like a shop or
something where do they need to go for
that thank you
no there are no footpaths
and we are aware of
the site being further away from
menden for example which includes the
services and facilities needed so for
that purposes um you know in terms of
sustainability it's it's some distance
away from shops and services so there
are no donors would pass immediately to
the site
any other questions yeah council
matterson
yeah was the um
the sustainability officer consulted
about this only i couldn't find a um
a comment i think it was on on this one
sorry council is that a question for me
yeah um sorry i didn't quite catch that
could you repeat that please yes sorry
yeah i was inquiring that i i couldn't
see um
a response from the the sustainability
officer
um
environmental management officer i think
um is the exact title um and i wonder
whether he
either of them had been consulted
uh the answer is no uh they haven't been
consulted i didn't think they were
consulted unless it was ten or more
dwellings but i could be wrong
i wasn't sure but i'd have to check that
but i i find it unusual that they would
be consulted with this level of
development
can we confirm that's good education
anyway i'd have to go away and find that
out um but i thought it was only 10 or
more we consulted them we do consult
environmental health as a as a whole um
and that officer sits with environmental
health um and we've consulted them a
number of times in this application so
as a team they would have been aware of
this application but i don't know we
haven't specifically consulted the
sustainability officer of that team um
again i thought the threshold was 10 but
more dwellings but i'd have to double
check so the answer is no but i'd have
to go back for something else
yeah i think it's a good educational
piece that we can all learn from so
absolutely right if you would john thank
you
councilman
um thank you um i'd just like to ask
about the
the hedge along the front of the road um
along from the site adjacent to the road
it says in paragraph 5.8
that it is to be retained
and the trees on the site are also going
to be um remain
um can you just confirm that the
access to this site is the same as the
one that's already got permission for
two dwellings
um or is there some change to the
the amount of hedge obviously have to
come down to make the access way thank
you
thank you um yes the access is as
approved previously thank you
and the the only bit of hedge to be
removed is just to make the width of the
roadway for the access that's right
that's what we've been doing and there
are no issues with creating a visibility
display
yes so the rest we don't have to get rid
of the other head just to make
visibility it's it all the visibility is
fine um no because the suffolk county
council highways have have been
consulted and they haven't raised any
objections in terms of visibility or any
issues in that regard so and there'll be
no further i'm taking out any hedges to
create more visibility thank you
any other questions
i have one question actually marta um so
on page 247
paragraph 1.3 it states it's not in a
conservation area yet i think from the
ward members
email
or letter that's contained in this
report it actually states it is in a
conservation area can you confirm which
it is please
um if we could go back to the slide i
could show you where the conservation
area ends thank you
okay so if you know the purple line i
don't know if it's very obvious but yeah
it's hatched in purple so that's where
um the conservation area is and it's
some distance away from the site
thank you
objectives or supporters do you have the
agent uh sarah roberts um sarah welcome
um
sorry that's my fault no problem okay
before we go there from the parish
council we will have the ward member
reading out a statement council warboys
thank you chair
this is the uh statement from the
wickhamskey parish council um
agreed at the meeting on the
um
last night night before last monday
night
uh wickham's keys parish council has
always objected to this development
because it lies outside village envelope
identified in the community consultation
carried out by the council
and
it this is also there's an original
objection
which includes this
wickham skate parish council also
considers six houses an over development
of the site
the parish council also considers that
the additional number of cars
and associated movements
six houses with three cars per dwelling
will be a significant and excessive
increase in traffic
the application rests on the fact that
it won't be visible
but there is no requirement for the edge
rows which ensure the lack of visibility
to be maintained or even an obligation
for the edge rows to remain
there is ambiguity in the application on
who is responsible for the maintenance
and protection of the edge roads
the application needs to be conditional
on this being clarified along with the
requirement that the edge rows be
maintained
that's from the clerk of wickhamskeith
parish council
thank you
thank you councillor
are there any questions for our council
of war boys as the parish
councillor mansell
i i think this actually might be a
question for the officer but it's been
brought to my attention by um what
council warboys has just been saying
um now if you look when you look at the
plan each individual plot appears to
have its own back garden but the front
all seems to be shared so can can you
please um perhaps give us some
explanation about the responsibility of
those open areas between the roadway and
the hedge line and the hedge at the
front of the property
thank you for the question councillor
i'm just checking the uh
if you get that plan of the site up um
you can see a sort of other frontage it
doesn't look like private gardens
okay thank you let's have a look
okay this area um the management of the
site after it is occupied is in for the
on for the owners of the properties to
to set up a company limited company to
to manage that and we don't normally
condition applications of this size but
conditions could be applied to to make
sure that the management afterwards
would be
in place um but like i said it's not
something that we normally do for
applications of design but it is
something that we could do
um that's not a question really at this
point we we leave it to debate on that
one count um mr pope g
i'll try and get you that uh council
mansell
here but there are
choices for the owner of the site they
or the developer who takes it on uh
ultimately
they could set up a private management
company where the six dwellings all
contribute and run together and that
deals with the essentially semi-public
open space areas at the front
the other choice is they
salami slice the various bits of land
that goes into the ownership of the
individual householders and even though
it's not their garden it's still their
responsibility individually to maintain
that piece of land that they're given
that choice is for the
developer
there is
uh no issue with us putting what we call
a landscape management condition on we
have done that in previous schemes uh
for us to get told exactly how they're
going to manage that area
i see no reason why that couldn't be a
reasonable request if in the debate uh
for this application
um
and i think that's probably as much as i
need to say on that
thank you thank you
other questions uh councilor matcheson
yeah yeah the um
i'm not absolutely sure that what the
classification of the settlement with
ski is it
it feels as if it's probably a
hamlet or something or no that's
actually the new that's a jlp isn't it
so i was interested at what the
classification actually was countryside
also it's actually countries okay um and
can can any officers or or council
warboys or somebody confirm page 244
that there are
three uppercut three permissions
um
which are all live
which would contribute eight dwellings
towards the settlement
is that right
it's probably difficult for council of
war boys i think so um
mr mr pokemon g please
if you could answer that or master if
you have that information
um thank you for the question councillor
um there are um yes so we have recently
approved two further dwellings to to the
south of the site
and um
i don't know the exact numbers of the
the the applications i know that the
current site is subject to an approved
outline and approved reserve matters so
is that something that you are referring
to
yeah
so perhaps we can
hear that a bit later on in the debate
then let's leave it to then and let's
see if it actually affects this plan
that's in front of us um so if there are
no other questions
then we're going to move forward and
we'll speak to the agent now which is
sarah roberts sarah once you get
going you've got three minutes
thank you
thank you um
there are no robust reasons for refusal
of the current proposal for this site
i'd like to ensure the members are clear
about the planning policy affecting it
in the emerging joint local plan the
council voted to allocate this site for
a minimum of five dwellings
for clarity the emerging joint local
plan pre-submission document
states on page 44 that all identified
home numbers are minimum figures
this approach to delivering a minimum
number of dwellings is repeated across
the entire emerging joint local plan
document
the site has the benefit of a spade
ready planning permission for two large
houses which
if applied for now would be against your
own policy
if you choose to go against the
officer's recommendation and against the
positive pre-application advice your
officer gave us you will be voting
against your own joint local plan
allocation
our pre-application advice and your
office's assessment of the current
proposal we've followed all the
protocols set out by yourselves as
council members and a rejection of this
scheme based upon objections by the
parish council representatives presented
by the ward member would in my view set
a damaging precedent in terms of faith
in your own systems
as stated in your office's presentation
the scheme received support from all
professional consultees in terms of
density landscape improvements and
screening highways and environmental
health
in addition we've received three letters
from local families who are keen for the
provision of smaller houses in wickham
skit
there are extant permissions for a total
of six large houses on three separate
sites along this section of grange road
two are already underway
what is being proposed here are six
considerably smaller and more affordable
semi-detached properties
this would balance the provision to a
mix of dwellings which should be more
acceptable to you both in policy and in
socioeconomic terms
we fail to understand why the parish
representatives prefer two
two more five bedroom houses over a new
supply of to two to three bedroom
properties which is one dwelling over
the minimum you have specified should be
on this site
i engaged with the parish council at a
meeting and i understand the planning
officer discussed with the district
member the justification for this
call-in to committee
in my view this application should not
have been referred to the committee as
it satisfies your own policies
far more than the extent permission
and constitutes no planning harm within
wickham skith thank you
thank you excellent timing um
questions please start with councillor
passmore
um thanks barry i'd just like to ask the
agent if we look at the plan on page
278
this is a detail but one of the things
i've always been concerned about since
coming back on this committee is the
making sure that driveways aren't as
porous as possible and we minimize
the level of paving i just wondered if
you look at the map if i saw the plan
there's quite a lot of paved area would
you be prepared to
compromise on that should it be given
the go ahead in other words i'm not
saying no paving at all
but from unless i'm completely wrong
the hatched area on this plant there's
quite a lot of paved area
and i think it um would be better if it
was permeable because looking at the
water in the driest part of the country
as many my colleagues will know some of
it's shingle but actually john if you
look at the other parts that go up to
the houses i just wondered if there's a
bit of compromise that would not affect
the uh plans particularly and there are
all sorts of
surfaces you can have and i think if
that's something we wish to do as a
planning authority i just wondered if
you could
clarify your position on that should
should it get given the go ahead thank
you
um yes what we show is a
shingle
shared driveway and then
it's indicated as paving
in the um in the private driveways
um the paving in the private in the
private driveways there has to be a
disabled
a wheelchair um usable hard surface
but from from one space
to the
um access to the dwelling so um but but
um
the even paving now
can be permeable so yeah we'd be very
happy to have permeable paving specified
thank you councillor e burn and
councillor mansell thank you
um thank you very much chair um this
sort of raised a question to me on
policy if i can ask john pateman g um
because i'm just a bit concerned about
the
we've got the draft joint local plan but
i understood we were giving little
weight to that and if this is a
countryside location i don't want i'm
concerned about whether we're which
policy where
takes preference as it were is it the
countryside because this building in the
countryside outside settlement boundary
or is it the um emerging joint local
plan just so i'm clear thank you
i thought for a minute it failed wasn't
going to let me say anything but that
was a great start
sorry
right okay um
yeah this is not going to be
straightforward or simple to explain
okay
so let's start from the very beginning
we have our development plan which is
the local plan and we have
the core strategy and in that policy
context in terms of those important
policies you have got
a countryside village and this is
outside of even that this is in the
countryside
but
you also have other material
considerations one of those material
considerations is your emerging
joint local plan
and that joint local plan
a few months ago we would have said had
limited weight
on the basis that
you have got a settlement boundary that
now encompasses this site and you have
an allocation of five houses that
encompasses this site
so you need to give what weight you wish
to give to that material consideration
at the same time we then have the
position where that
examination has stalled for the time
being and though in the middle of
working out a way forward in terms of
turning the current joint local plan
into a part one and a part two document
but even if that has stalled members
should perhaps be mindful that the
evidence base behind the allocation
has essentially said this is looking
like a sustainable place for development
to go
um
so you you've got to bear that as in
your in your waiting as well
setting
that's the policy context if you like
where we are
but of course we also have the nppf and
the tilted balance uh context to
consider as well so we're weighing up
what are the important policies in
regard to this development but we also
have to weigh up a number of factors
within the nppf now housing supply is
one element of that and i know that may
be a feature of other applications
coming forward today
in mid-suffolk we have more than five
years so there's not an automatic we
have out-of-date policies due to that
particular aspect
but we also have to consider how our
policies
conform to the nppf
which is another part of the test
in the nppf and in this case
we would say that not all of our
important policies for housing supply
conform entirely with the nppf as it
stands and that is why we have to look
at the tilted balance to say that can we
grant planning permission unless there
is any
demonstratable adverse
harm
for
granting the application
so
in a nutshell
it's not straightforward
because there was a lot of factors and
you have to go through a whole process
from looking at what the most important
policies are
all the way through to where we are
there is a third element to this which i
know applies in another case later
which is where within the nppf
whether the tilted balance is a part of
it or not the tilted balance disengages
due to something in regard to heritage
assets or flooding now neither of those
apply in this case
so the tilted balance does apply here
but um you know it's a very complicated
sort of
path you have to follow and you have to
keep changing
different places and in different parts
of the junction
in the end
you have to decide whether you consider
this to be a sustainable location for
development
and whether this development causes harm
in that context
thank you
councilman
uh thank you um i'd just like to ask the
agent um
how these uh new dwellings are intended
to be heated
air source heat pumps
are there any other questions for the
agent council mattison
yeah um
i think the the um comments from from mr
payment g actually
feed into the question really uh that
the
i think it's conceded that this location
of wickham ski has has pretty limited
sustainability uh in terms of its
services
and
i wondered whether
in the light of the um
the negative sustainability point
that's that's highlighted there
whether whether you're prepared to go
beyond
building regs levels of sustainable
design to to balance that out
[Applause]
sarah any points any answer to that oh
is that to me i'm sorry
right
um
nowadays all
no maybe i can't speak for all
developers
um the small developers that we work
with
in the area
are
very aware of the attractiveness of
high levels of sustainable construction
and
particularly this week
if if properties are going to have low
um energy consumption for
for heating
um
then
there's everybody's got to got to move
in that direction i mean we're all we're
all going around well i certainly was
last night going around
readjusting my heating controls so that
they're only on half as much as they
were for obvious
reasons so
if we can if we can build houses which
are
um have all sorts of um
carefully thought out
sustainable
um
features then yes we would we will do
that i'm not entirely sure
um how that fits into an actual planning
condition
i'd be i'd be
i'd be i'd be pleased to hear
how that if if and how that can be
conditioned we might we might leave that
to debate then and i think you're right
it's a bit of a difficult question to
answer to be honest with you so we'll
leave it to debate and we'll come back
to it i'm sure john
can we get the agent's
participation at that stage
i think we're jumping with uh mr ian de
prez
just to say that obviously stating the
obvious this lady's an agent she can't
make a promise without her clients
instructions as well i think is
important
and mr payment g
um okay i'll get a beat or blunt to a
certain point we have to determine
what's before us um and ultimately
the
position you need to debate if you go
into debate is if you are going to
impose conditions uh to seek
higher insulation and other matters that
you may wish to discuss
you will need to decide whether they are
reasonable
and relevant and necessary in the
context of this development and your
current policy position
and obviously i can advise you on that
as need be at that time
i was just going to uh
make the comment to ask the question
perhaps that says presumably these
houses will conform to the new building
rigs upgrading is it
june or july i'm not quite sure which
does shift
uh the goal posts uh not quite as far as
we'd like but
on that one we're getting a nod from the
agent you'd like to confirm that please
yes as i understand it the building
regulations changed this summer
and
after
if any submission which is made after
that
any
commencement of any individual house on
the
even if a submission is made before
the changes in june um any individual
house which is started after that would
comply with the new regulations so yes
there's no there's nothing's going to be
starting on site before june unless
we're forced to build the two
five-bedroom houses which would need to
start before april but um but yes
absolutely all the houses will comply
with the new building regulations
thank you any more questions for the
agent please
okay in that case we're going to move on
to the ward member thank you for your
time sarah we're going to move on to the
ward member now which is council of war
boys
thank you chair
uh my reasons for asking this to be
considered on are on pages 270 to 271.
alkaline planning permission for this
site was given in november 2019
and the office's comments at the time
were
this application seeks to erect two
dwellings the sustainability of the
development has been taken into account
when considering this proposal
and it is not considered that the
proposal conflicts with the nppf
to such an extent that would justify
refusal of the application
the sites on the edge of the hamlet in
open countryside and at the time not
meet any meeting any declared local
housing needs
pages
244-245
summarize the parish council's continued
opposition to development on this site
this site was not identified for
development at all in the joint local
plant from july 2019
it does appear in the new online version
as lso 1
with a land availability assessment for
five dwellings
so
at present
there is a fallback position for two
large houses with five bedrooms and a
double garage each the houses would each
be on a generous plot
and there exists detailed layout plans
showing how cars can enter and turn with
each plot
this new application is for six
seventy-two detached houses
sixteen bedrooms in total and parking
for 16 cars
it is proposed
that in front of the houses there is to
be a shared access incorporated
incorporating an 8 meters by 8 meters
turning area there is no detailed
management plan for shared areas which
presumably includes the entire rope
frontage
it is claimed that the design takes into
account orientation
however this is inaccurate the building
ridges are oriented north south
making any potential uv generation
unviable
your choice is then between two big or
six larger dwellings
does this proposal represent better
design
there are questions already regarding
sustainability
and this proposal being larger is surely
less sustainable than the previous
application
it is also
about how much weight to give to a
previous permission for smaller
development
what has deeply concerned the parish
council is this final turn of the screw
where a developer who has permission for
a smaller develop development
comes back with an inflated development
and expects the previous decision to set
the precedent for further development
thank you chair
thank you councillor any questions for
the ward member please
council feels that question thank you
just briefly we
frequently hear parish councils
requesting
smaller houses that match the local need
is it that we can see don't see it that
way that they would prefer larger
dwellings which
bias the
available housing to somewhat more
wealthy clients
that hasn't been factored in the
discussions
at the paris council i their largest
concerns are with
[Music]
the increase of traffic in the village
the
preservation and continued conservation
of the hedgerow
the problems with the existing problems
with drainage
on the road
in front of this development
the questions of housing needs hasn't
arisen at all in the parish council and
this development isn't seen as actually
sort of
meeting any existing housing needs
thank you counselor any other questions
for the ward member
okay in that case so we're going to move
straight to debates who wants to start
don't be shy
counselor passmore
right thank you very much chairman well
having listened to a lot of the
discussions um i have to say i actually
rather like this development
i completely understand the issue about
um concerns there may be with
over-development but i have to say
living in the next-door village
i do know quite a lot of people that
would um
be very very pleased to see a similar
development such as this with the
smaller houses and so on and we do need
as i've said many many times helping
people to get into property smaller
houses not everybody wants a large house
and i think
knowing the road here it's actually the
semi-detached house i think is very
appropriate um obviously there's already
outline planning permission on the site
for a different term
level of housing anyway but the house is
opposite from what i remember of course
are also semi-detached anyway and i
think there's a lot of thought gone into
this
and it does fit
with the general demand i think within
the area
and i think therefore i would like to
formally propose
approval but there are a couple of um
conditions i would like to to uh note
down
one of them is about the permeability of
the paved areas if everything possible
can be done to make sure they are porous
notwithstanding was very pleased to hear
about disabled access which i completely
understand
clearly there are some concerns locally
regarding hedgerow management trees and
so on can we make sure please there's a
robust condition on that
that it is a really really good
landscaping scheme and i think the
application by the way does respect um
biodiversity very pleased to see um the
details there
as regards sustainability we haven't got
time to discuss sustainability this
morning because we could be here for a
whole week deciding on what
sustainability actually is
um the issue here though if we're
looking at energy sources and knowing
the
terrible price rises there are and
probably more to come it sounds to me
though this is
inadvertently already been taken to
account by using um heat source pumps
and so on so for me
in my opinion i do think it deals with
that and looking at this
application on its own merits what we
have before us um i think there's been a
lot of thought going into that
i actually don't think um the
development this is going to really
really make a huge difference to the
traffic clearly there will be more
traffic but the current rate of progress
you're going to need a mortgage to fill
up your car and use it anyway
so therefore chairman i would like to
move approval with those couple of extra
conditions please thank you thanks
passmore thank you for proposing i do
need a second of that proposal before we
move forward
anyone no
in that case i'd like to second that
proposal with the condition that you've
applied i will now move back to debate
uh initially i've got councillor mansell
uh thank you chair um
given that we've we have the starting
position in this site of having two
five-bedroomed houses already got
permission and as the agent said um
that's that's spade ready and they'd be
starting to build them
whenever if they didn't get planning
permission for the um three pairs of
semis um for this new scheme
um
i think
if if we get the right conditions
on this we will actually end up with
more environmentally sustainable homes
because they'll be starting after june
or they'll match the new
um building regs i too often harp on
about smaller dwellings and i think that
having
six modest sized dwellings in gizlingam
um
is probably better than having
two
executive large executive homes with
huge gardens that will be um out of the
price range of
of your average family who might want to
live in gizlingam i'm not particularly
familiar with gizlingham it's a small
village i have i have been through it
but
wick i'm sorry not disney well we can
ski i have i have been through it it's a
small place and often small villages um
end up with with an aging population
because they're all big houses uh with
with uh couples in who can afford such
large dwelling so i actually far prefer
these six modest dwellings uh on this
plot i'm a little bit i'd like a little
bit of clarification about exactly what
conditions councillor passmore
said he i certainly think we need a very
strongly worded protection of the
hedgerow fronting the road
um uh he talked about landscaping
um and uh
permeable driveways i wasn't quite sure
if he was uh
suggesting that we also conditioned some
sort of landscape management plan for
the sort of semi-shared
area whatever it's called um
i certainly think that we need to put
something in to make sure that that area
is maintained and managed properly and
i'm not sure if that was quite on um
councillor pasmore's uh proposal so i'd
like a bit of clarification for that but
um i think i
i'm i prefer this to the two big houses
uh it's not ideal but we've we've got
that as a starting position
thank you so picking up on that and uh
council password if you agree we're
looking for a condition to protect that
hedgerow for many fur damage and also
landscape management scheme condition as
well
mr paintman g before we come back to you
tim
it doesn't actually say hedge but the
conditions in your papers on page
253 you have the landscaping scheme
to be implemented as the approved plans
and obviously the approved plans show
the retention of the hedge as part of
that but you also have an additional
condition that says protective tree
fencing uh specifications to be agreed
tree
we tend to stretch that to tree and
hedge but like the word hedge can be put
in there
cause password thank you
uh so now we're gonna move along we've
got uh councillor matthiasson first
thank you yeah i think the
the parish council is
um
is wishing that that this site was not
developed
um
unfortunately that
that's no longer um an option that's
available to us
i mean i think as a countryside village
our policies would would suggest
um
you know a handful of
extra dwellings every few years to match
um
you know expanding expanding need um and
we
we haven't actually
stacked it up exactly but
they're getting eight
already um
which which
other things
you know if we hadn't already got
the two five bedroom ones then i would
say well look
a countryside village they've got enough
on their way they don't really need some
more
but
um
given a choice between
what's got permission and this
then it's difficult to um
you know to say that that we should
refuse it really
um
i mean it's a pity but that's where we
are with with this site at the moment
unfortunately
and um
certainly
it's good to hear that we will get the
the new upcoming sustainable design
standards
um
so i i can't
quite refuse it um
sympathizing with the parish council as
i do
thank you uh moving to council mayor
please
thanks jim um
i think
the increased number of houses is a good
thing um
so i do believe this is a better
development i do have to take issue with
um
councillor
about sustainability
as i understand it this is a full
application and therefore design is an
issue that comes into question
designing houses when we have a climate
change emergency that orientate north
south seems to me to be a complete
failure
if you look over the road the house is
built 1970s
largely north south but some of those
roofs have a east-west orientation
so in my mind this this is a step
forward it's better than five bedroom
houses but if you're giving a crayon to
a 10 year old and try and draw him a
house he'd have drawn boxes just like
these boxes
and with a bit of luck he might have got
the orientation right
i'm sorry but i don't see that the the
design of these houses is fit for the
21st century because the orientation is
wrong
so
whilst i see it as a better you know the
increased number of houses is better
than five
i'm not going to support this
thank you uh moving on to counselor
eben
um thank you very much chair um if this
was a um blank piece of paper
application you know coming forward
without any history
you know i'd have had serious um issues
with it you know on sustainability on
being in the countryside you know i
don't think we should go against our own
policies however if we were to um refuse
this one today then obviously we would
have two houses built there anyway
um and
i would prefer to see um
smaller houses built full stop
um whether they're in small villages or
towns because i feel that's what we we
need
i do have issues about the
sustainability of it per se
both the design as councilor mayer has
mentioned and the fact that in terms of
once you step outside the
hedge as it were there's no footpath
there's no
um you know ease of access for walking
and i think that is a real real shame
um
i would like to see
again the protection if this is approved
for the hedgerow
my concern would be that over time these
houses might decide they each want their
own access onto the road
and we need to prevent that and keep
that area
looking countryside as it were so i'm
slightly on the fence about this at the
moment but given that
if we don't um if this isn't approved
the we're likely to have two large
houses anyway i think i'd be on balance
more in favor than not thank you chair
thank you councillor and we're going to
move on to councillor field please
thank you
i think i'm largely in favor of this
development
and the mppf does allow development in
the countryside as long as it's not
isolated and i can't see that this is
isolated not the houses immediately
opposite and quite close to the village
boundary although not adjacent to it
it is has been pointed out in our
emerging local plan
that
has arisen from a
reasonably sensible process
i do feel that uh switching two large
houses for six smaller ones matches
local need
better or most villages will believe it
means local need
and particularly as we're told there are
other large houses being developed in
the village so so there is a
spread in size matching
the spread of
needs of the population
um is it
is it sustainable well it's clearly
within two miles of a a larger village
with plenty of facilities two miles
nowadays is a long walk but
not impossible on your bicycle so
i'm inclined to think this is more
sustainable than some
locations i'm pleased to see that we'll
be meeting the dune building regs which
moves some way towards our requirements
on
improved environmental performance
it would be nice if one could mount
solar arrays on the roof if they were
the right way round
it may be that solar arrows are so cheap
nowadays and it could be done even on
not optimally
orientated roofs
i definitely believe we should condition
not only the sort of
um construction of the open space the um
landscaping but the ongoing maintenance
of that
it's probably a sensible thing to do but
just make sure that that does get done
and does get continued onwards
and i think
that about finishes what i want to say
basically agree with most other things
that have been said thank you
councillor whitehead please
thank you um
i found myself very finely balanced on
this although i um i've lost typically
the words
said by councillor mayor
i mean look looking back at the
plants with the two large houses that
are already
approved from what i can see there both
the roofs of the houses and indeed the
garages are orientated
so that they could effectively be
plastered with solar panels which would
then supply power to the air source heat
air source heating
um for hot water and indeed for electric
vehicles in some ways to me those two
large houses
seem much more sustainable than the the
the this new proposal
and what's a bit disappointing that the
member referral form has that era where
it says the development is within the
conservation area so it seems ashamed to
me that
it couldn't have got through the editing
process to have that corrected that's my
thoughts at the moment
thank you any other questions council
matches
yeah i i think that councilman mayer
does
bring bring us back to it to a very
important point about the the
orientation and i i mean i
you know ideally i'd like to see the the
sustainability officers uh commenting on
every application
um and i think if they were commenting
on this one they'd they would say what
councillor mayor has just said and it
does seem to me that the
if the agent took away the thought that
this committee
um
is
is comfortable with the six
smaller properties on this site
and that
recognizing that the need to achieve the
i think it's 19
improvement that the building rigs are
going to bring us um that really
taking it away and actually
create you know getting the right
orientation there is quite a big sight
here it should it should be
um within the width of the architect to
get the thing oriented correctly and um
and get the
significant contribution to the power
for the air source heat pumps so i i
think that
you know i'd like to just leave that
thought with the agent
that that might be a better way of going
forward that there wouldn't be
a need to bring it back to committee
if the design was just changed given
that we've accepted the principle up to
and including six properties already so
that's just
an additional thought it doesn't mean
i'm going to change my view that on
balance
i would support but and while i'm at it
i would just like to say on the um
conditions
uh the weather um and i'm sure he has
previously agreed with this councillor
passmore would accept that um that house
martins need a home as well as the
swifts
and indeed we should remember the
hedgehog highways also in that condition
so with those thoughts um
council pasmo
i'm always delighted to approve anything
that would help her biodiversity such as
hedgehog huts
and obviously house martin
cups
they are their cups no i mean i think
hopefully in time that will become part
of our policy anyway so um
then we wouldn't have to debate it
further but no i do agree with that
absolutely
mr pope and g please
well i've got a minute looking at the
block plan it does actually mention
hedgehogs and it mentions a beehive
on the block plan as well um as well as
uh swift boxes and back boxes in terms
of the conditions recommended to you
we've slightly gone a bit weird here
i'll be perfectly honest we've got swift
boxes to be installed as agreed but
we've also then got biodiversity
enhancements to be agreed prior to
occupation i would probably say
biodiversity biodiversity enhancements
is a bit of a coverall and would cover
all of that so the necessity of the
swift boxes as well isn't needed because
we'll deal with it all in one condition
there but um i think we've got that
covered quite sufficiently in terms of
the recommendation
thank you are there any other questions
no sorry debates any other points
council mansell i just wanted to say
before we go to the vote can we have the
additional conditions read out clearly
so we know what we're voting for thank
you yes certainly um we spoke to you a
bit of time are you good to go well um
in terms of he's as recommendation
my words today apologies it is as your
recommendation
um when uh it was um
recommended and seconded we had
landscape management plan to be agreed
which would be to deal with that front
area mostly we had paving to be
permeable
i heard two extras later but i don't
know if they were included which was a
change to the protective tree fencing to
include hedges for the point of
clarification
um
there was something else but i forgot
what it was was there any others
now that cup that's that's already
covered
i think that might be it
yeah landscape management scheme
condition i have one further condition
i'd like to now recommend just having
looked at the block plan one last time
um there was an existing access to the
south east corner of the site which has
got a field gate on it
and i just looked through the highway
conditions and there's no highway
conditions to stop up the existing
access so i would like to add a
condition to stop that access up
i would also note that as a classified
road any further accesses in the future
if anyone moves in and decides they want
to try and create the access of their
own would still need planning permission
any in any event because this is a
classified road so that doesn't need a
condition because it's already covered
by the need of planning permission
thank you
any other points
i've got a couple um obviously i support
this i support it for a number of
reasons one i think it's the right place
for this development i think that six
houses that are affordable um fits the
need of the rural areas rather than two
large expensive houses
as far as vehicles go that's arguable as
to whether there's more or less vehicles
a two-bedroom house doesn't have three
cars generally and a three-bedroom house
doesn't necessarily have three cars
either so it's a bit of a yeah it's a
guess isn't it so i don't think there's
a massive difference
i'll come onto the solar panels i think
the point is absolutely
relevant councilman the fact that
it seems to me
that a lot of the proposals we get in
front of us don't consider orientation
and they should and maybe that's a point
for the future um
but i've just been on to because i know
these things i know that obviously the
prime is facing south about 30 degrees
angle that'll give you about 100 and
i've just checked my figures and on the
one of the sites that i've looked at the
um
eco home essentials dot co dot uk great
reading um that that sort of backs that
up but it also says that if i'm east or
west i still do get some benefit from
the sun from the rising sun and the
failing sun it's just not as good and it
drops from say 100 down to about 86
percent but that's variable dependent on
the orientation as in elevation of the
panels so it doesn't mean you're not
getting anything okay so we need to
balance that out a little bit it's not
as good as it should be though and
that's a really important point i agree
with you completely um but wouldn't it
be terrible if all houses faced north
south we'd just have loads of terrorist
houses in the countryside wouldn't we um
you know this there's a
double-edged sword really but it is an
important point
um i am supporting this and if there are
no other points i'd like to move this to
the vote please
but first of all can we just confirm
these conditions
so the conditions is to approve as
recommended by officers in your papers
with the additional conditions those
being a landscape management plan to be
agreed
paving to be permeable in the areas to
be agreed
protective fence and so protect the
fencing for tree and hedges and the
stopping off of an existing access to
the southeast corner
everybody clear on that
okay thank you in that case i will ask
the governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote there thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress and
you're out
thank you members chair that's seven
votes four and one against
thank you carried
let's go on my notes and then we'll move
on to the next agenda point we're now
going back to eight a and i'll ask the
area planning manager john patengi to
introduce the application to the
committee which is land east of warren
lane and west of kres meadow way
elmswell suffolk john
um happy five minutes comfort break stay
back in five minutes please
welcome back everybody hope you're
suitably refreshed and we're now going
to move on with the agenda 8a john
payment g please
thank you
so this is the application for the
outline planning permission access to be
considered but all other matters
reserved
for the erection of 44 dwellings
including bungalows affordable housing
open space landscaping and associated
infrastructure
this application was presented to
committee on the 8th of december
and resolved to defer in order to seek
further information on the impact of the
quarry to the south of rounds well
so just to recap
this is the site so it's the south of
elmswell
it's enclosed on number of sides by
existing development infrastructure
it is outside the current settlement
boundary so it's just down there
and
it has an allocation in the joint local
plan of limited weight
for
38 dwellings it also had a previous
planning application for 38 dwellings on
part of the site as well
and of course that has expired last year
just closing up and just looking at the
aerial photographs so the top half
of the site is surrounded by
essentially the settlement boundary and
also development on all four sides
moving down to the bottom half
development is to the north south and
and east start again north east and west
to the south it's open uh to the open
countryside and you've got warren lane
to the left there that goes off to the
south towards
lawn farm industrial business park
and and other road networks
that's the settlement boundary as it
stands uh in your current local plan
there are no actual constraints as such
for the site itself
nothing's moving try again there you go
um we have very detailed indicative
layouts uh showing how the plots would
all work
we have a number of shallow
sustainable drainage systems
proposed with this scheme
which is mainly to the north and running
along the eastern edge
and just going into close-up to see how
that development would fit
in uh within the existing development
okay
so we have an indicative mix
which we find acceptable
and we have
like a fairly detailed
understanding of how the sustainable
drainage would work in this location to
ensure that it is a shallow
system
[Music]
and just turning to photographs now
these are various shots taken from parts
of the site as indicated
and as you can see the most exposed
point is coming
from the south towards the village the
village sitting in the background but
you will see this development
as you approach along that wall lane
taking it further afield
you can see the village is on a ridge
essentially as you see it from distance
and
if you go all the way around to the
eastern side of elmsworth and look back
you can just about see perhaps that
northern part which is essentially
surrounded by existing development
although the southern part is sat behind
the trees
this is an older
shot i will say
and then just to clarify this is the
southern part of the site
looking from the development on the
opposite side of the road
out to the
southern views
and just looking back
and then we are inside the more northern
part of the site
in that sort of green open space at the
moment
which is surrounded by existing
development
and we have a footpath that always looks
like the beak of the
layout um we have a footpath that goes
off in one corner
as well
so the reason we deferred it last time
was to look at the quarry matter
further
and this has been detailed and full in
your reports but there are safeguarding
zones for consultation and this includes
part of the site
so just to clarify
this is uh the site is roughly in here
and this is the quarry that we're mainly
referring to with its safeguarding zone
to pull that into close
uh
looking at it closely it's been provided
by suffolk county council
and the question here is it's not just
the existing safeguarding zone of the
quarry as it stands but there are
expansion plans indicated here in the
red and of course that expands that
safeguarding zone
as well
and it's the expanded safeguarding zone
that covers a part of the site before us
just to clarify
and of course this is an indicative plan
that's roughly and this is my drawing in
terms of putting the blue line on so
there is a degree of error please bear
that in mind um but essentially that is
roughly where that safeguarding zone
will be i will say though that if you
take the scale of the safeguarding zone
at one scale and try to take it all the
way down to a different scale the
thickness of a line can get very wide so
it is a judgement here
just to clarify where the expansion area
is
uh proposed in terms of the current
quarry for extraction purposes there
as recorded in your papers we have
discussed the application with suffolk
county council the conclusion being that
the county as the minerals authority
consider that the proposed housing
development will not be prejudicial to
the operations of the quarry
it will be for the future application
for the expansion which hasn't come in
yet
for to expand the quarry if and when to
consider the existing amenity of
existing residents so that's those
right now
in terms of elsewhere and any that are
obviously approved in the meantime if
this was approved
um your officers note the expansion will
be an extraction area the main noise
will consider the south east corner of
that site and the development would most
likely continue the three to five metre
high bund around the quarry
that that's there in part at the moment
we also as officers note the distance
and the woodland uh as well
in conclusion
um
the site is not within the current
safeguarding zone but will partly be
within the future expanded zone
as we have shown but our conclusions is
it would there isn't an issue here at
this time for us to seek refusal on that
basis
further to
the last committee we have also had
further discussions with the county on
the obligations sort
in respect of his application
education the cycle linked between
elmsworld and warpit and we have
received further justification in
respect of those obligations so we have
altered the recommendation from last
time to now include all obligations
sought by the county and the district
as detailed in your papers so there is
no
reduced obligation requirement we are
seeking everything that the county have
asked for
therefore in conclusion this is
considered to be a much improved
application in terms of space
sustainable drainage compared to the
previous scheme for 38 but now includes
all of the obligations and contributions
that neither the previous scheme or the
allocation itself within our joint local
plan include didn't they don't include
those
it is noted uh in an another application
on the agenda we have given very limited
weight to the planning history
whereas in this case we have given it
some weight
these are very different sites uh the
scale of development is different
especially
in terms of 44 versus a far smaller site
but especially in terms of the
provisions of the nppf and paragraph 11d
the main difference being the context of
heritage harm that applies to that site
but does not apply to this site and
therefore heritage harm does not
disengage the tilted balance in this
case the tilted balance applies in this
case
there are also differences in terms of
housing supply as we know but also the
assessment of
the suitability of the location this is
a very sustainable village uh compared
to the other side
um
so
let me just catch up sorry so the
conclusion being
that we have considered the overall
benefit of the additional land we
you know it is more than what is in the
allocation or the previous scheme
but we consider the scheme demonstrates
high level of potential design layout
without harm to amenity the scheme
includes wider improvements to the area
and until in terms of the tilted balance
to grant permission unless any adverse
impact of doing so would significantly
and demonstratively outweigh the
benefits approval is recommended thank
you
thank you and members do you have any
questions
kassariba
um thank you chair i just wonder with
regards to the um quarry um
i understand there are complaints about
noise and dust from the quarries do you
know how many there are from the
neighbouring
um estate such as chris meadow way thank
you
no i don't the county didn't provide
anything for in that respect
carson madison
[Music]
um
unfortunately i couldn't find anything
from sustainability officer again on
this one this one clearly um it isn't
less than 10.
and so i wondered what happened about
that
and
i think the
the other question
yes the in your conclusions
age 52 um yet could you
could you say really why
why does the the conclusion seem to
compare
this application
application
rather than comparing it with the status
quo
the
first question was in terms of the
sustainability uh sustainability officer
they were consulted um
i don't have a reply recorded they were
consulted a couple of times throughout
the life of the application so in terms
of
why we compared to the previous scheme
this has been ongoing for some time the
previous scheme only expired last year
but at the same time up until
christmas
the site is also allocated for 38 houses
within your emerging joint local plan
so
we also have the evidence documents
behind that allocation to say that 38
is deemed to be considered acceptable in
principle in this location so for the
majority of the site and we'd appreciate
it doesn't cover the entire site but for
the majority of the site we have a clear
steer in terms of your policy position
and we have a clear stare in terms of
previous history which we have given
weight in this case
um
i apologize if it comes across slightly
biased towards the history but it is an
important factor
uh as
considering the evolution of how this
site got to be allocated it was part of
that consideration um and therefore
we considered it to be given weight in
this in this context but you are right
you also need to give context to
all other material considerations and
that includes the current local plan and
position of that
you also have land here that is in
addition to
what has been accepted in the past
with the additional of just six houses
but of course we've also had to weigh
that in the balance to say that
it allowing the site to expand in area
of land allows us better opportunity to
have a far lower density that would be
more in keeping with the rural edge than
we felt the 38 approved before would be
and ultimately allows enough space for a
far greater degree of landscaping and
sustainable drainage area to have a
shallow system uh than the previous
scheme would have allowed for
so in the balance
they are the conclusions and it is a
complicated judgment to make because
you're giving weight to different things
in different ways
okay
that's the field please
thank you
looking at page 47 powers 39 310
your analysis of
policies of ours that are inconsistent
with the
mppf and policies which are consistent
and therefore the weight that should be
applied
and in 311 you say
based on the assessment above
given the inconsistence policy is
important to the application the tilted
balance is considered to engage right
and then you go on to look at 11d one
and two
i noticed the next application we look
at after this seems to have a completely
auto online completely different
set of policies analyzed as being
consistent and being inconsistent
so while i understand your issue that
perhaps
part of 11 d2 would would
disengage activity balance i can't see
why the two analysis are not consistent
i have a correction to make to the next
application um which is relevant to that
um so i i can't really deal with that
here but i need to deal with it when we
get to that next application um
ultimately
the other point is that it's not just
policy it's how you apply apply weight
to those policies in the context of the
location of the application so the
location of this application is adjacent
to
one of the more sustainable locations we
have in the district as opposed to
another application that's literally
next to a few houses in the middle of
nowhere and you can't apply those
policies the same way in its judgment in
its conformity with the mppf so there is
there is differences there
there is a professional difference
perhaps as well that does come into it
you know i will give you an office as a
we try to be as consistent as possible
with each other but i appreciate there
may be a few inconsistencies there
um
i've taken
my analysis of what is consistent or
inconsistent in terms of the mppf from
the appeal history that i feel was
relevant to this case and i've mainly
looked around on the wall pit appeal
which is one of the more substantial
appeals that we've ever had in this
district
where the inspector did
take us to task over the policies that
we were using and how they were relevant
to the nppf
uh i don't believe i've gone beyond that
but i'd be
more well that might be a separate
discussion but
i'm happy with the assessment i've given
you for the purposes of this application
in this location
thank you i mean obviously my concern is
as a counselor i'm being given
consistent advice from
you guys as professionals and i notice
the differences as i read through these
various papers
and
your explanation that that depends on
the location
um you know a
a third party might assume it depends on
whether we want to approve or not
approve the application so i'm concerned
about that possible
well let's view the
so the most important policies in the
context of putting a housing development
next to a sustainable centre
versus what are the important policies
putting a housing development in the
countryside
but of course in the case we've just had
they're very different but ultimately
the other material weight given in that
case was to the planning history and the
previous approval of two houses
um
so you are trying to balance these
aspects
and they inform how you imply what
policies and how much weight you give to
those policies as well
the important thing between this
application and
alex's application later
is how the tilted balance engages in
respect of the heritage position
and they were very different criteria
within the mppf because of that
so
our path
splits apart quite significantly at that
point in terms of what we feel was
relevant policies that have been applied
to this site i take your point it's
something maybe we need to look at
further to find a better way to
summarize this within our reporting to
you
know even please
thank you very much chair um
just to be clear on the evidence that's
um in the
sheila for the
drafting of the joint of the draft joint
local plan which is
on hold um that only covered part of the
site so with that there isn't any
evidence covering the
site that extends well beyond the
southern
line of the housing
that southern housing line in the in the
village so
so can i just be clear that we haven't
got any evidence
covering that southern part of the site
that extends out where the tree band is
beyond the south side thank you chair
um no um you're quite right um i i tried
to be trying to be helpful uh i have on
page 44
uh included
i tried to do it as a comparison table
but um the allocation
in the joint local plan
you know there's even a story behind
that it gets complicated but essentially
the allocation
in
in terms of a map
is that there's actually the text
allocation refers to the entirety of the
site at one point which includes the
extra land that we're talking about here
so there has been a journey um but i
think i would be safe in saying that
what we're looking at in terms of the
limited way joint local plan position is
as shown on on page 44 there
any other
questions okay thank you we're going to
move on then to the parish council peter
dao from elmsworld parish council
appreciate three minutes from the moment
you start your
chat thank you thanks chairman
um i fear the common sense is likely to
go out the window here
we must instead frame our very firm
objections with reference to nppf
where we are asked to weigh the benefits
against the adverse impact i always
think that the the tilting balance is
quite often from our point of view
tilting at windmills but never mind
for the community the benefits are
indiscernible
with 190 houses just finished at the
bacon factory the first of 60 occupied
this month at poorly crescent
a healthy chunk of the 240 at weatherdon
road completed
106 well underway at ashfield road and
hot off the press 86 at school road for
those keeping up we're at 680 plus
and could throw in 190 oak lane six more
rashfield road
and suggest that in mppf's words the
needs of the area are well met
the developer seductively offers elmsl a
range of benefits from their proposed
delivery of much needed housing
this on top of the 700 i just listed
they've tried hard to make a case
their proposal goes beyond what we were
braced for i.e development within our
settlement boundary on designated sites
we had accepted with poor grace the
permission granted in 2018 for 38 houses
it took our village boundary to the
limit of the development envelope beyond
this is countryside where wheat can be
grown now worth 300 pound a ton
and you saw the crop in in the offices
photographs
we're now asked to stomach an extension
of that site creeping towards the
extremely troublesome poor neighbor
which is lawn farm corey
for an extra six houses we are asked to
allow the development boundary to be
breached
clearly opening the door to further
expansion to the east linking up with
this same developers weathered and road
site
we told our residents that the pressure
would lessen when a five-year housing
supply was a shot in the locker against
such predations
here we are asked to resign on this
long-awaited chance to draw breath
the developer claims that the
hard-fought housing supply figure counts
for nothing
when in his opinion the structure which
it seeks to underpin
is out of date just as last time i was
asked to address you on this application
i'm appealing for the common sense that
i fear maybe out the window
the developer has his houses in effect
38 of them within the boundary fitting
neatly into the development pattern
the village has enough houses
738 and counting to satisfy all
reasonably anticipated demand the extra
six are to be built outside of the
village opening up a clear opportunity
for further development
i would ask that we
persuade
the powers that be to revisit the 2018
permission the clear steer to approval
that your officer is indicated
if members decide that the benefits to
elms will outweigh the incursion into
our countryside and the threat this
poses to our further environs then we
have to ask them to explain i need you
to summarize them as a corollary to any
such decision
i will print this in the newsletter the
elmshall newsletter
and i invite any members who support
this
to give us their reasons in print
thank you
there's actually no need to do that but
thank you anyway
members do you have any questions please
um
cassian matcheson
yeah the the um
the joint local plan as you
know is is
described as emerging
and the
the neighborhood plan
um process is is
um dismissed uh page 46 as um does not
have
um
and um i i wondered if you could just
tell us a little more to what extent it
is
emerging because it seems to me that
that it's been in
in truck in traction towards
um getting adopted for rather a long
time and if you could just help us a
little bit understand what weight if any
we ought to give that
um particularly compared to the weight
wheel attached to the joint local plan i
could just jump in that one if we're
talking about weight to be applied we'll
come back to mr payment g for the answer
thank you
okay okay
peter thank you chairman
neighborhood plan
is now ready for pre-application deposit
and as i understand it may actually have
gone for pre-application deposit
it has taken an inordinately long time
because unfortunately we were too keen
jumped too early we didn't know what
we're doing and now that we've met
suffolk we now do so do you so it's now
ready for submission
any other questions
okay thank you thank you for your time
okay we'll now move on so we're now
going to ask the agent james bailey
please and again you have three minutes
start from the moment you start talking
thank you
good morning chair members i'm james
bailey and i'm the planning consultant
that has been working on the current
proposals on the land that sits between
warren lane and chris meadow way in
elmswell
contrary to my normal style i should
look to be brief this morning
we last met at the december committee
where the merits of the scheme were
discussed concerns were raised regarding
the nearby quarry expansion and there
were also some further obligations being
requested by suffolk county council
i'm pleased to report that both of these
items have now been successfully
discussed confirmed and agreed to the
satisfaction of your officers
as i recall at the december committee
there appeared to be a general
acceptance that the layout being
presented before you now
represents an improvement on the
original consented scheme
on this basis i would therefore
respectfully request that members follow
and endorse their officers
recommendation and approve this
application this morning
thank you very much
thank you members council eber do you
have any questions please
thank you very much chair um
this the original application went in in
2016 um along with the um weatherton
road applications for 240 homes um
why is it that you've suddenly come back
with an increased size on this
application and and not gone ahead with
building as you've done on the other
side thank you
thank you uh i think we would probably
all agree uh or hopefully so the the
the scheme that we're presenting now
seems to make a lot more sense and use
of the space
we've gone into a lot more detail in
what is presented to you uh
this morning and obviously at december
committee
than perhaps was presented
previously by that i mean in terms of
the type of houses uh the the type of uh
of of orientation in terms of the the
suds features uh and also the the
landscaping perhaps that hadn't featured
perhaps as heavily from 2016 onwards but
i think the the difficulty was uh
bringing forward the 38 units are in
that form it may well have been that a
reserve matters was going to come
forward later on uh that perhaps would
have had difficulty in providing that
what i think we've got now in front of
us albeit an additional six units is
something that works better
in terms of its setting and in terms of
its improvements and enhancements that
it's looking to provide
classroom
yeah
um thank you very much for that that's
um
can i ask then why
the suds features and i understand
obviously this geology and geography to
play but why they're what those type of
features are open space whatever isn't
in the area that's south of the building
line whereas you've extended houses out
into the into the southern part rather
than leaving that as open space and suds
and so forth thank you
at the end of the day the uh
the application process is one where we
come in and we speak with uh with the
offices through a pre-application
process involving others in terms of uh
your uh
your fellow counterparts at the county
council including the likes of of
landscaping and ecology and drainage
that is where we've had the discussion
with your uh your counterparts uh in
terms of the the drainage that we are
looking to propose as you quite rightly
say councillor eber there is a variety
of different types of features that you
can see uh on the scheme in front of you
some of which are our largest sort of
depressions as it were
others of which are uh are more sort of
linear swales what we've provided there
is something that is sufficient
to meet the number of houses that we're
looking at now in terms of landscaping
and in terms of ecology and the
biodiversity that is providing as well
and that is why we've got a
recommendation for an approval from from
the county council drainage floods team
thank you councillor field please
the question really is will you be
telling potential purchasers how close
the quarry will be getting
absolutely and i believe that they are
probably already aware
any other questions from members
okay we're going to move on to thank you
for your time we're going to move on to
the ward members now so it's uh council
sorry
i'm sorry i didn't see your hand sorry
so i i i was going to make a point about
the the drainage but actually it was
relatively covered i will just say this
we we had negotiations with the floods
team at county uh we met with them uh on
occasion and
one of the conversations was about not
just having a big giant hole at one end
of the site and filling it you know
with water and
being very deep
which could have been the case here what
this scheme is is spread out across the
site in various different swales and and
a shallow system which means that you
effectively don't need the big
attenuation basin right at the bottom of
the site hence why it's not there you've
got more landscaping there rather than a
big big hole in the ground um the idea
behind this one was if you equalize it
across the site because the site in its
geography allowed you to do that
you would lessen the impact but actually
of the subsystem itself and actually
have more opportunities for landscaping
to be wound within the site itself
it was the approach that was taken on
board and it's more compliant with the
up-to-date guidance the county now gives
obviously guidance back in 2016 versus
the guidance of this year from the
county has radically changed in respect
of drainage because they only really
would just happen running at that point
four or five years ago
thank you so we're going to move on to
the ward members so it's uh councillor
sarah mansell followed by councillor
helen geek i believe
thank you um the previous application
for 38 dwellings has now expired and
although that decision is material this
application now needs to be determined
on its own merits let's not forget that
back in 2018 msdc did not have its
five-year land housing land supply
now that we have over nine years land
supply there is much less need for this
contrived plot to be developed for
housing at all
elmswall is already being subjected to
many large new housing developments as
already outlined by the parish clerk
and we still have no satisfactory or
sustainable solutions to the traffic
issues and the primary education
facilities in the village
i've always considered that the access
arrangements for this site are plainly
daft warren lane is a narrow road
it's always made much more sense to me
to access this plot of land from kres
meadow way where the pedestrian cycle
access is now proposed
warren lane is already heavily used as a
rat run for all but the largest lorries
from the lawn farm business park where
both bacton transport are scun and
scania east are now based
and there is the ever expanding
cafe metropolis as well as other traffic
coming off the a14 at junction 47a
where there is only um one-way exit
the responses from the suffolk county
council minerals team didn't seem
particularly clear in respect of any
impact uh caused by the expansion of the
quarry
they seem to cite that other
developments have already begun within
the impact zone so what is a few more
the development site on wetherdon road
which has several dwellings inside the
expansion impact zone was granted
planning permission before the 2020
minerals plan came into being
and and there is as yet no planning
permission for the expansion of the
quarry and any impacts will then need to
be taken into consideration when that
permission is determined but if the
expansion of the quarry is already in
the plan surely this is a foregone
conclusion and there will be impacts on
any new homes within this impact zone
and in response to councillor ebon's
query about complaints from existing
residents from the quarry it's an
ongoing regular basis uh lots of
complaints about noise dust size of the
bund and dirt on the road
um the future expanded primary school in
this in elmswell will still be
insufficient for all the growth that's
already planned
and suffolk county council don't seem to
have a firm idea of what yet to do
will they be building a new school in
the north of woolpit to cover the future
expansion of both woolpit and elmswell
or will they expand the existing woolpit
primary school or will they do both
either way some elmsworld children will
need to be transported across the a14
for their primary education well before
any new cycle or pedestrian route is
completed
i note in the officer report it states
that the density of this new development
is less than what was in the previous
application but is this necessarily a
good thing the district and elmswell as
a village need smaller market dwellings
we don't necessarily want another load
of large executive homes on large plots
and the indicative plan does show an
appropriate mix
but the indicative mix of housing both
market dwellings and homes could provide
us with a good number of those
much-needed smaller properties but only
if there's a is a condition suggesting
that the reserve matters is broadly in
line with the indicative mix outline
stage
and you'll need to be clear on the
indicative numbers as i think there was
some errors in the dna
the written numbers don't tally
withdrawing um it would also be good if
more of these new homes could be
oriented to make most of solar gain and
were heated by renewables
should this committee be minded to
approve i hope that you will consider
these suggestions as well as other
conditions relating to the pedestrian
access to the site
the fort path links from the site uh to
both warren lane and kres meadow way
should be cycleways uh shared access
ways not just footpaths
the most obvious route from these new
homes to the private existing primary
school would be valcresmeter way
uh please also condition uh the proposed
footpath link shown on the indicative
plans to the south of the site to create
a link to some permissive footpaths
which would give access to the wider
footprint network to the south of the
village much used by dog walkers and
many others particularly since the kovic
lockdowns
i think we also need a condition
relating to proposed play area in the
public open space provision um and also
the indicative layer including drainage
base and should be adhered to in any
future reserve matters application and
don't forget include as many
environmental sustainability measures as
you possibly can because no doubt that
will come back to haunt us at reserve
matters stage thank you
thank you before going further uh mr
payment mcgee please
uh just to mention that in the
recommendation before members condition
nine controls the market mix of
dwellings to be agreed including number
of bedrooms and space standards
prior to or concurrent wood reserve
matters so that is to be controlled
the
other issues there will essentially fall
under the theme of layout which is not
part of the outline before us and can be
picked up at a reserve battery stage so
it's a balance of
pre-loading or allowing reserve matters
to be judged on its merits later
i would say you can cover those easily
enough with reserve matters in respect
of
some of the layout issues referred to
but i'll leave it there
thank you before we lose any questions
uh because we're going to go to council
geek in a moment are there any questions
for councillor mansell
council madison
i didn't
which
which okay which issues are that that
council mance was just talked about are
our layout
issues
i wasn't clear which you know it didn't
seem i mean footpath makes our access
anyway and and um well not entirely the
footpath links within the site itself
would be part of the layout the um
so the linkage to the um
forgot the name of the other road sorry
um
yeah so within the site any linkages to
that point could be part of the layout
for the consideration i thought i had
got it
uh
controlled
uh bear with me
so we've got on-site management open
space junction improvements to warren
lane uh improvement of warren lane
itself contribution to changing the
speed limit oh here we go uh the cycle
pedestrian access to crestment way and
warren lane would be secured that's in
the 106 agreement so that is there so
that's already approved ahead of any
reserve matters so
that one i had to do as a 106 agreement
because you're
it's securing an actual linkage in in in
terms of that but the actual layout of
the cycle path itself would be a matter
for the reserve matters within the site
any other questions for council mansell
i have one um she talked about the
warren lane and the issues with warren
lane although there are three i think
it's three conditions already within the
proposal would they satisfy
your concerns or not
no
they're they already had a scheme for
putting passing places on warren lane uh
several years ago and there are um a few
sort of bits of wider road with a bit of
curb on but they're um
i mean as you saw in one of the photos
cars just drive up the verge and the the
uh field is being worn away by the by
the amount of traffic that is using that
road there is um i believe as per the
original 38 there was a lot of
discussion about the junction with um
warren lane and church road and that is
secured the improvements i presume
they're the same as they were for the
number 38 but
it uh it is a very uh sensitive road um
because of all the development at the
lawn farm quarry and they the lore says
there is there is a weight limit but the
biggest trucks that can possibly can
still use it because of that one-way
access at junction 47a anything coming
out of lawn farm if they want to go
westbound on the a14 they are supposed
to go all the way to hawley um and get
joined the a14 there and obviously
that's quite a long detour so they just
and
they they they either nip through
elmswell um and go along warren lane
but there's a weight limit there or they
nip down wood road wall pit and nip
through wall pit um so it does generate
a lot of traffic so warren lane is much
more heavily used than the size of the
road um
shows really it's it's it's not designed
for that amount of traffic
thank you uh we'll move on now to
councillor helen geek
thank you chair
um i'd like to start by echoing and
supporting the objections uh and points
raised by councillor mansell and by
elmsall parish council
this extension to the south beyond the
allocated site in the draft joint local
plan makes this development not just
slightly larger than the allocated area
but half as big again virtually and so
it will encourage further sprawl into
the countryside uh not only towards that
noisy dusty quarry but also as
the parish council have pointed out
towards the
new estate at wetherton road to the east
in addition the many objections that
were received by the council at the time
of the previous expired application the
one for 38 dwellings they seem to have
been largely overlooked although they're
still relevant if not more relevant to
this application
they come from elmsweil and weatherdon
parish councils and from several
residents in both parishes and mainly
refer to traffic considerations on
warren lane
since 2016 um as councilor mancellus
said that now has to accommodate
increased traffic resulting from the
development of the lawn farm industrial
estate and that ballooning site at the
stag cafe those commercial developments
don't have proper access to the a14
those junctions do not work properly
particularly 47a so traffic coming from
these sites has to go either through
woolpit past the primary school and the
health center or through hawley new
street and weatherton or if they take
the shortest route of course they go up
warren lane turning left at the accident
black spot of nuisance corner and down
through the school road junction in
elmswell you must be horribly familiar
with the school road junction in
elmswell by now
the uh
people appear the county highways team
appear only to have considered the
immediate effects on warren lane but as
we all know once you've got into your
car you're unlikely only to go as far as
the next road we need to think about the
wider area
lastly of course approving yet another
small increase to the population of the
village means that the decision to
approve the current school extension
looks ever more like an expensive
short-term sticking plaster
but
yes how about the conditions if you are
minded to approve this development
the there's a condition that an energy
scheme be approved prior to commencement
which is great the applicant at the last
meeting seem to be happy with heat pumps
rather than gas boilers and it seems
absolutely essential now to get those
formerly in place
and yes lastly on a rough count around
twenty ten of the dwellings on the
indicative plan lack a south facing roof
which of course is much better than the
previous application that you considered
this morning but still it could be
better please could there be an
expectation that the final layout either
improves the number of roofs that could
be used for solar panels to a high
efficiency or at the very least doesn't
reduce them thanks
thank you
do you have any questions for members
okay thank you and thank you for the
ward members i'll now open this up for
debate who'd like to start councillor
eben
um thank you very much chair um thank
you to everyone that's spoken today
i'm very unhappy with this application
um
and i've got so many points i swear to
start um
we need to we have to consider this
application from from scratch as an
outline
it extends well into the countryside
beyond the southern
line of the housing in elmsworth it's
outside the settlement boundary
it doesn't comply with the part in the
mppf where we've got nine because as we
have a nine and a half year housing land
supply
it's well beyond the um draft joint
local plan um allocation even though
that allocation is now in limbo because
of the joint local plan
um
and as i said it's outside the
settlement boundary
warren lane is i know very very well
it's a single track lane the
lorries virtually driving to the fields
in order to get down that lane
and encouraging even more usage of it is
just
is crazy accidents waiting to happen um
and it's in a few passing places isn't
going to improve that
i don't understand why the um if they
wanted to have a larger area again why
does the development the actual housing
development need to go further into the
countryside um
in in fact with with all of this um you
know as it's been said elsewhere's got
over 700 new homes um the mppf talks
about need for housing um there isn't a
need for housing um
the original site that was smaller that
was within the settlement well not not
within the settlement boundaries outside
of but it was in line with the
line of housing for southern side of
elmswell um could have been acceptable
but i cannot support
this application going beyond and into
the countryside and chair i would be
happy to um
put forward a
recommendation for proposed refusal of
the application if i was to have um a
seconder for that thank you chair
so we do have a proposal for refusal
but i'm going to give you a bit of time
actually to consider why
so we'll just take a breather give me
the reasons and then we'll look for the
second day
oh you mean now or you're waiting for
sorry um
as
i understand it i'm allowed to ask for a
slight adjournment to discuss with the
um planning officer and the legal
officer with regards to reasons um i'm
also allowed to ask whether i've got any
um
members of the committee that are minded
to um support it otherwise obviously
that's um
if there's if no one's going to support
that it's a bit pointless asking for a
gentleman yeah no absolutely and you do
have those rights and i'm going to allow
that as well so um yeah let's let's do
that um before we go on to that um
counselor matcheson
yeah i
i mean i
contrary to my colleague um i i'm very
um uncomfortable with um
starting the debate with a proposal uh
which has um
other members of the committee have done
that
already once this morning
and um
but
um
given
where we are
i i
i think there is an arguable case
for refusal
uh and so i i would um
like to facilitate the discussion that
the councillor ebon has requested with
with officers and legal um by
seconding it
okay so are you seconding it
or are you going to wait till you've had
that debate i i i
because what i'm planning to do right
now is recess for a few minutes to allow
this conversation to take yeah well i'm
i'm i'm helping facilitate that that'll
happen without if you're accepting that
without
a second or then i will withhold
i'm happy we're going to recess and
debate this
councillor matson is in fact saying
informally that his mind would be minded
to support um second councillor eben's
resolution subject to
the reasons for it i dare say and i
think that's quite enough i think
councillor eben was concerned not to
waste the committee's time if she was in
a minority one didn't know it and that i
think we know she isn't likely to be so
we are sensible to carry on so guys um
we are going to we are going to recess
for around about five to ten minutes so
you can have that debate um with the
legal officer and the governance officer
uh sorry with the planning officer um
and then we'll come back to it
uh ladies and gentlemen uh welcome back
and thank you for allowing us that time
to recess it was important there's some
important questions needed to be
answered um it's not uh common in what
we've just done but it is allowable and
therefore we took the advantage of it
but before we go any further i'd like mr
paintman g to come in please and explain
a few things i'll then bring in mr de
press and then i'll tell you what we're
going to do next thank you
so
the interesting thing of course that's
just coming to my head is planning is an
art not a science and
it is it is the point that this is a
democratic system and there is a degree
of judgment it isn't a tick box exercise
in this case you have been given my
professional view on the application and
what i consider as a professional
planning officer to be the merits of the
case and what should be approved
i am not therefore capable of giving
counsellory burn
unbiased advice when i have essentially
been dealing with this application for
some time and i feel that there is a
risk that if i give advice even though
trying to be neutral as i could be
that it would be biased and
challengeable
outside of of these walls so on that
basis
i
if further advice is sought to look at
reasons for refusal
it is my opinion that it needs to come
from another officer
uh and i believe this is confirmed by
ian duprey as appropriate action
i have never had to do this before but
it does highlight the issue of trying to
be a case officer and and a neutral
manager at the same time in the same
forum
um but on that basis for the risk of the
council i'm going to ask a chair to
consider deferral of this item on that
basis to allow another officer to be
available to give that advice at another
occasion
as a further complication
i handed my notice in a month ago and i
will not be here
at the end of april and i'm so i don't
know how quick this will be to return
and it may be another officer has to
look at this case and take it forward on
that basis in any event but
that is the advice i am giving because i
feel that if i was to give
sound advice about reasons to refuse
there is a challenge in that because i
am compromised in my professional
opinion
uh in this case and i would have
preferred to have a secondary
essentially officer to to balance that
but as that's not available i'm
suggesting we defer it thank you
thank you thank you for being open and
honest as well uh mr dupree please
do yes checking of the
constitution sorry i'm just putting the
password back into my computer to excuse
me and it may take
a moment
more but i think since we've started
sorry i can i'm on i can be heard
hopefully we we've started the debate
and we've had a presentation and
discussion of this
i think we need we need a resolution to
defer is my understanding i will double
check that but i mean if i may say i
think there may be members here who
would be who would have been minded to
take another view and i don't know all i
know
and it would be i'd say that they would
well i've never presumed to tell any
member how they should vote in all for
many years working local government they
they would be
so minded to um
oppose and and
then for all we know there might be
another resolution to do something else
other than refuse or defer but that's
so if we if we if it's um
[Music]
having had if those who were minded to
make this step
were um
wish for the deferrals to take place in
accordance with mr payton g's advice
then we would
um then i think we would vote on on that
but i mean what shall we i think we'd
better just look at the cards pokemon g
while he's looking up please sorry if i
may ian um
there was an occasion and i don't know
if this is applicable uh where
the the matter was deferred for the
officer to seek advice on the risk of a
refusal yes um oh yes that can be that
yes
that is quite possible
that happens very very one of my other
employers west suffolk has it in their
constitution if members are minded to
refuse contrary to the officer's
recommendation the officer
politely says i really think you need a
risk assessment that is the protocol
says members are
effectively enjoined to defer for to
receive advice on the risk assessment
that actually might be a sensible way uh
around this i think thank you for that
mr payton g that's it it might be the
point though that that's one step too
far because the point here we're trying
to work out is the procedure of giving
you advice which has not been possible
and therefore biasing the position but
if we can take it to that point that
might be another option but i think
that's for you too so i think if if
if there were a resolution to defer so
that advice on the um
probabilities and risks and potential
reasons for refusal before we go there
just a couple more comments from anyone
any of the members uh mr cancer is
possible yeah i think um bearing in mind
the controversial nature of this and the
potential difficulty i think that's an
imminently
sensible position so if you want a
formal resolution i'm happy to propose
that the other the other point about
this so um chairman is i think
this may not be the right time to do it
but this has been backwards and forwards
sometimes and i think for all planning
committee members to get a really good
feel i actually think the site visit
also because of the complexity of this
might be advisable now this may be an
inappropriate time to say it but
to be fair to applicants
local people everybody and for members
of the committee to really understand
what is going on i think that might not
be a bad idea but as i said i don't know
whether you can run the two together but
we'll hold on to your absolute for a
moment and we'll come back to you
councillor field
yes i personally am concerned about a
number of aspects of this i think that
the
way forward is
suggested to
defer while we
do a risk assessment to look at the um
reasons for refusal or whatever and
investigate the risks that they're
therein contained
thank you before we move for another
proposal we do have a proposal on the
paper um are you willing to withdraw
that proposal councilory burn
thank you chair yes i would draw that
for the purposes of moving forward of
this thank you chair council madison
happy
thank you
okay um so
let's sub the
let's have the right words before we put
the proposal forward and i'm i'm looking
for a proposal so listen in
switch on again i think council passport
indicated that he was minded to make a
proposal
that this application be deferred
um
for the
uh committee to
receive advice
on the risks of a refusal
thank you and in terms of that as well
um site visits mentioned what's the
protocol for that
well i mean i think it's been it has
been said before this this commit this
council has
been sparing in its habits of sight
visits but it has done it occasionally
when it's been a matter of
significant concern if but if counselor
passport saying he thinks it's a good
idea then other members agree that's
that can be done too
thank you
guys
the other thing in order to help out
with john as he is sadly leaving us um
clearly they will take time to get this
clarified but it may be sensible
to um if we do agree to do a site visit
when the new planning officer perhaps is
in position because we don't want to end
up with all sorts of different people
i'm just hoping to
well a clarification of what would be
the better most appropriate time to do
it so there's none of this
no further reserve backwards and
forwards and um these things happen but
we need to make sure we're in the right
position to make the decision um
uh appropriately in the in the future
as well
council matters
yeah i i i'm i mean i'm i'm in general
agreement with with where we're going
what i wanted to to
say i think particularly to the legal
officer um that it seems to me that that
from what mr payment g has said
what we're we're deferring and asking
for
is
advice about the case in general
and it might be
wise to to include exploring
the risks of of refusal
but the there is that first thing before
that second thing uh and um
i'm personally quite familiar with
warren lane but i'm not wouldn't
disagree with the idea of a site visit
at the right time which i'm sure we can
leave to the chief planning officer to
judge
thank you mr potentially
so
what we do need is um a conversation
about what possible reasons we might be
minded
um
in order to take those away and come
back to you with a report on those
reasons
i mean i think sure if i may share if i
may add i mean we've had a conversation
with councillor eben which she won't
mind some of it being replaced in public
i'm sure but we
we we haven't the officers have noted
councillor ebern and i'd say councilman
matheson's concern about
the
incursion into the countryside and the
contrary to current statutory policy on
traffic
and it might be added i'm sure from what
was said in committee the anecdotal
evidence that they have from the ward
member that there have been
uh complaints about amenity issues
arising from the proximity of the quarry
um
we heard that from the other from one of
the ward members
do we need is that accurate and do we
need to answer it if i may ask
country ben
um thank you chair and it's just also to
sit where it sits in position wise with
the mppf and the um
nine and a half year housing land supply
that that we have and just while i've
got the mic chair i'd be i think a
site visit will be very very helpful
thank you
thank you so we have a proposal
for deferral for the reasons quoted
and and a site visit yeah that can be
incorporated as well that'd be fantastic
is that correct
yeah makes sense um so we do have
proposals do we have a secondary
councillor field thank you
therefore i will ask the governance
officer to take this to the vote
electronic vote
thank you chair so members your vote now
reads that application number dc2102956
be deferred to enable the committee to
receive advice on the risks of deferral
and to carry out a site visit of the
application
refusal sorry thank you
sure
i don't i don't think that wording
has
indicated that we we
have a need
okay um i think we need to say it very
carefully so i'll bring in mr
potentially and we'll just take a couple
of minutes yeah let's do that let's get
it right so in the next meeting if um an
officer sorry if a counselor needs
further advice on reasons for refusal
within the meeting they will have the
opportunity to have
two officers available rather than one
on that occasion this is the point of
process in in terms of the meeting
itself
separate from that you're deferring
to clarify the risks of refusal on the
grounds of traffic countryside impact of
the further housing quarry and
seeking more information around uh if
there was a refusal on housing need
given that nine-year
housing supply so they are those factors
so that will come back
the meeting will start again and if
there is a refusal motion put forward
then
then if that person putting that forward
needs further advice they will have the
opportunity to do so with someone who
isn't the case officer which isn't the
opportunity you have at this moment in
time
council past more happy with that thank
you council madison
councillor field
perfect okay in that case i will ask the
governance officer please to take that
to the electronic vote
thank you chair members just one moment
and i'll put that into the boat
so to confirm the vote will now read
that application number
dc2102956 be deferred to enable officers
to receive a report
regarding the risks of refusal as read
out by the area planning manager
and to carry out a site visit of the
application
is everybody happy with that
so that vote is now in progress
thank you members chair can i take your
vote verbally please
thank you so that is
seven votes for deferral with councillor
mansell not voting as she's the ward
member
thank you i think that was important so
um yeah thank you for all of that thank
you for the
input from the offices it helped
massively okay we're now going to move
on we're going to move to um
agenda point 8 b which is the lands to
the rear of the lee's coits meadow
stoner massable in suffolk and i'll
invite the coast officer alex scott to
introduce the application to committee
alex
all right apologies chair for that
slight delay
um yes members this is uh item 7b in the
papers application reference dc 22
double zero
land to the rear of the lees in quite
some meadow in stoner massable
the application before you uh seeks
outline planning permission
with matters of access to be considered
all other matters reserved
for the erection of up to five new
dwellings
and
new estate access
to coits meadow
and
the five dwellings would uh
follow demolition of one existing
dwelling uh so
then we're getting a net gain of four
well that's that's the proposal anyway
so uh five new dwellings demolition of
one net game of
four
now the current application follows
previous outline and reserved matters
applications
on the site as referred to in the
officer
report and further details are provided
for members attention in the in the
bundle information
so if we move to the
presentation yeah so this is um the
location of stoner asphalt within the
district uh for the avoidance of that to
everybody
and the site location within the
immediate
area so we have storm asphalt here and
you might be able to see the the site
just uh
i'll add it in red there hope that's
clear
and the approximate location of the site
was in the village
and we have the uh the major planning
constraints on the site and the ones to
be aware of are
the settlement boundary of the village
and the majority of the site and the
location of the proposed wellings lies
outside of that
that boundary
uh the other um
major constraint is the the listed
building here at orchard farm grade two
listed
referred to in the papers and um
and the impacts associated with that
we have an aerial view of the site here
so
the site
comprises approximately half of this
existing uh horse paddock
and
the location of
the leaves which is the existing
dwelling proposed to be removed
to make way for a new access
to
to the new dwellings which are proposed
in this paddock
now the existing access
here
to the horse paddock would not be used
as part of the proposal
and
if we come onto the red line
we can see that that doesn't extend all
the way to uh
to that field access here i have some
photographs of that as we go through
now um the proposal doesn't um include
any um any details of layout indicative
or otherwise so what i've done here is
provided what say what a layout may look
look like this was the indicative layout
provided with the outline application
the 18 reference which was
previously considered and approved
although we didn't have details of
layout landscaping or appearance
considered or approved
at that time
and you can see here indicated uh
existing dwelling at the leaves for
boats to be removed to make room for the
access road through to five dwellings
and this shows
how they may sit um
for a feature application if minded to
approve
and this was the previous reserve
matters layout which was before
committee recently the dc 21 reference
which was uh
previously considered and
refused for the reasons given in your
papers
uh onto some photographs this is uh the
access uh
point from the street to uh the coits
meadow estate and probably see the
existing uh dwelling at uh
belize in the in the background
um here moving into this state so this
is existing dwelling proposed to be
removed
now i just want to point out this is an
older photograph
showing existing silver birch trees
which have actually been
been removed
and then
further into the estate again looking
back to to the lees
and this is the junction of course
meadow with the street
just to give an
idea of the existing situation
there and the opposite direction
they're looking looking east
this is the existing uh
access to to the paddock and the field
beyond
um existing track which would not be
used um as part of the current proposal
and it goes past uh the grade two listed
building which is orchard farmhouse
which is uh here
and we have a better view of that
building
there
this is taken from the existing
access to the uh to the horse paddock
this is uh the listed building here
orchard farmhouse and we're looking back
towards the street here down the track
uh the existing access looking into the
majority of the sites
and then past the site to the field
beyond this is the listed building again
then a view from that uh
track um across the uh existing paddock
majority of the site existing uh
building there
then back towards um
and he just might be able to make out
the roof lines of dwellings in uh quits
meadow there
and this is um
yeah the hedgerow which goes along the
uh rear of the paddock but the
development is not proposed to extend
that far
just to give you an idea of what lies
beyond that and this has been provided
by the applicant previously
and there's a view from orchard
farmhouse across the site so hopefully
that's that's helpful there
location plan
um so the officer's recommendation in
the paper
is for refusal
when the previous outline
permission was permitted
the council had no five-year housing
land supply we're now able to
demonstrate in excess of
nine years that's 9.54 years as per the
latest information published in uh in
february
the
the site is outside the settlement
boundary
of a secondary village um
and um yeah there is uh considered to be
significant harm in terms of the um
uh the heritage asset uh the setting
significance thereof
to the because of the five year house in
land supply the
uh
the public benefits associated with the
proposal are
reduced
we think and
therefore
um the public benefits to the to in
terms of the heart balancing exercise
with the list of building as well as
well as the um
the balancing exercise in the
application in total
um overall in conclusion um officer's
recommendation that um
in the planning balance the proposal
weighs negatively as set out and does
not represent sustainable development uh
therefore recommendation of refusal
thank you
thank you before we go to members um mr
pompeo wants to add a couple of points
yes thank you
um just to clarify
page
145 of your papers uh under paragraph
4.3
provides that the mid-subject currently
better i'll just read this out it might
be easier
bits of it currently benefits from a
housing land supply that is significant
in excess of five years as evidenced and
with referenced above
there is therefore no requirement for
the council to determine what weight to
attach to all relevant
planning development plan policies in
the context of the tilted balance test
just reading that
might be taken the wrong way it is in
the context of only part of the
paragraph 11d of the nppf
while there is
housing supply in mid-suffolk that is
above five years and that element in
itself does not engage the tilted
balance there is still the judgment on
the conformity of the development plan
policies with the nppf
and we know that the local plan does not
entirely accord with the nppf and
weighing that judgment we've gone
through that a bit today
there's also a matter of judgment in
terms of location merits of the proposal
and other material considerations that
have
an impact on the weighting that you
might make
and in this particular case there is a
further factor given the provisions of
the nppf
essentially states we should grant
unless the application of policies in
this framework that protect areas or
assets of particular importance provide
clear reason for refusing the
development proposed
foot note 7 of the nppf lists what these
assets might be and this includes
flooding for example but it also
includes designated heritage assets eg
listed buildings
um it also includes conservation areas
so while the policy position can be said
to engage the tilted balance at this
time the heritage position is considered
essentially to disengage the tilted
balance
okay
so
it is not simply a matter of housing
supply it's a matter of your policies
but there's this extra factor that
essentially says when you're dealing
with harm to a list of building in this
case
we can say that we are disengaging the
tilted balance because of the provisions
of paragraph 11d
and that is what we're saying in our
recommendation in this case
a bit complicated to apologize but um i
just wanted to clarify that the the way
that sentence was worded wasn't the case
that we're just disregarding the
development plan policies
in fact we we've got to is a wider
position than just that
next set questions to uh mr pope mcgee
and also to alex so we'll start with uh
council mayor please
so
the tilted balance isn't engaged because
of the heritage issues
was the tilted balance engaged last time
if if so why didn't the heritage issues
carry the same weight
so as in last time you mean
um
there has been different
changes in the mppf wording um they are
almost updated every two years now um
i can't recall
how long ago was that last application
decided
okay so we've had two changes to the
mppf since then um i would have to go
back to check
specifically the is a
footnote
at the bottom of the uh the paragraph
that refers to which assets are included
in the list i don't know when heritage
was put in there and i'd have to check
if however it was there and we didn't
pick up on that at that time
then that's a position that we we should
have picked up at the time but we can
only deal with the application before us
now and we are saying that that is a
factor that we
have we need to push forward to you as
our recommendation
kelsey matthewson followed by councillor
passport
yeah
if can you just help me clarify that i
mean i'm a veteran of the 2017 decision
and the 2019 decision
already um
the the
[Music]
um
the outline permission um
1804191 etc um is that still extant
and if if so
um
are we comparing
this application with something that's
currently got permission
it's my understanding looking at the
time limit condition for that alpine
planning commission that the time limit
for submission of further reserve
matters applications to that outline has
expired that would be my take on it john
okay
please thanks barry um
yes so we just got to look at the
application forget about all the other
stuff that's not actually relevant
so but the point about this is in the
dim and distant past many years ago we
used to get applications just to grant
residential permission and that was it
you didn't have to have an indication of
housing so the difficulty i see with
this it doesn't actually it says up to
five residential dwellings well that's
fine they could be
enormous small big whatever they could
all be in one place they could be in one
corner they could be spread out so
it actually makes it quite difficult
what i really need to know then normally
we would expect for an outline
commission for residential development
with up to five or whatever the number
is an indicative plan is not absolutely
set in stone of what the layout would be
now we haven't got that
so i think that makes it difficult to
adjudicate but is that what we would
normally expect when we look at it
because i haven't seen one
quite as
open as this or vaguely whichever way
you like to say for a considerable time
thank you
indeed
okay the
i actually prefer if i'm perfectly
honest with you a red line without much
saying because i can i can genuinely
understand what i'm dealing with rather
than sometimes indicative
is helpful but it's also not helpful if
it's not what you want to see
but
an indicative plan is something that
is there to help demonstrate that the
development is possible
and if you don't have that indicative
plan
there is a you're not aware of at least
one way of doing it that is possible
um
so
you are
if you're saying there's insufficient
information to judge that there's a
scheme that's demonstratively possible
without causing harm to amenity or the
heritage then ultimately that is your
judgment to make if you have sufficient
information
and if in this case
there isn't an indicative plan
you have less information to work with
to understand if there's a possibility
of something decent coming along at
reserve matters
um that's for your debate
but we can't in we can't insist on an
addictive plan
helpful let me put it that way that's a
personal view of course you don't have
to agree with me um
and i haven't looked this is my mistake
was there pre-application advice with
the officer before this was this this
application was submitted please uh yeah
sorry not this specific application
though
yeah
cause rebound please
uh thank you very much chair oh if it
was only straightforward um i would
like to i'm
just with some comments made now now
again unclear but we we are supposed to
take into account as some kind of
material consideration that there was a
previous
outline application that was approved
that's correct
yes and sec yes there is it is material
yeah and secondly you give is up to you
and secondly the um
that footnote about heritage assets was
in is in the 2012
national national planning policy
framework so obviously we should have
looked at that earlier but would it make
would it make
a difference
in terms of the
layout because i think from before there
was understanding about the having a
bungalow there or something so it was
is that impact considered that's what
i'm asking thank you well the other
thing of course a few years ago is our
housing supply wasn't in the position it
is now so of course that's another
factor of engagement of that tilted
balance or not so
it's not as straightforward comparing
the situation a few years ago to what we
have now what we're saying now is that
we do have a housing supply so that part
of
the assessment ticks the box in terms of
till to balance but what we've got is
the heritage thing that we still feel
given where heritage has got to with
this site is relevant because we're
identifying the harm here so we are
saying that if balance is not engaged
on this merits of this case as it stands
before us
we're clear in that position um i think
yeah we could look in the past and
possibly find some faults with the
decision at that time maybe but we don't
need to go drag that up now because it's
not relevant to this
in that context
are there any other questions
okay we have no one from the council we
do have an objector who's uh beverly
brady probably have three minutes from
the moment you start talking and thank
you for coming
thank you chair and thank you committee
we wholeheartedly concur with the
recommendation the planning team that
this application should be refused
from the recent committee meetings
attended i'm sure you're all very
familiar with the history of
applications for this site
since the previous outline permission
was granted in 2019 there have been
several failed attempts to gain approval
for reserve matters
laters figures show that mid-suffolk has
a nine and a half year housing land
supply which is nearly double the amount
required and clearly today's situation
is very different to that in 2017 when
this all started this is a greenfield
site outside the village settlement
boundary and stretching into open
countryside it wouldn't add any value
and our secondary village doesn't need
this speculative application there's
already agreed development plans for 66
houses in more suitable sites
quaits meadow comprises six dwellings of
matching build and style
demolition of one and construction of an
access road through the middle would
represent a close offer close this would
significantly damage the character of
our cul-de-sac forever
the proposed axe access road sits on a
blind bend an accident waiting to happen
our road is already busy daily with
parents dropping off and collecting
local school children
our living conditions would be severely
impacted by disturbance as a result of
noise headlights vibration and loss of
privacy and it goes without sight saying
that this would be magnified during the
demolition of the me's the leaves with
even more disruption mayhem and loss of
immunity
the cap
the council state in their report that
the proposal would result in an overall
moderate to high level of environmental
harm it considered to result in harm to
the character setting and significance
of the listed building orchard farm and
its surrounding with no result resultant
benefit to outweigh that harm
the impact on this heritage asset has
consistently featured as a reason for
refusal in previous applications from
the very first one in 2017 that was
refused both by the council and planning
inspectorate on appeal to the most
recent reserve matters application
refused by this committee back in
december
it's quite clear to us that this
proposal is untenable as proven by the
fact that all reserve matters
applications have been refused the
proximity of the listed building is
never going to be any different the
proposed development will be out of
character with the surrounding rural
area and outside the settlement boundary
we therefore fully support the planning
team's recommendation that this
application is refused please allow us
to put an end to this constant shadow
which has been hanging over us residents
for the last five years
thank you
thank you perfect timing do you have any
questions please for beverly
okay um so we don't have uh but
i don't have any supporters
don't have an agent so therefore i'm
going to now move to debate
who would like to start
sorry
oh sorry
poor eyesight i'll put my glasses on so
there is a world there is a ward member
statement so this is from susie morley
he's the ward member and resident of
stone and asphalt the proposed
development site lies outside the
village settlement boundary so housing
development here is not automatically
supported
we have a housing supply land supply in
excess of five years and a village has
already taken significant development on
the other side of the road
this development where the football
field is far exceeds the requirement for
local people to live and see their
families grow up in the village
this proposal will result in harm to the
character setting and significance of
the nearby grade 2 listed orchard
farmhouse and would result in harm to
the rural character of the site and its
surroundings
in the words of our planning offices the
adverse impacts of the proposals are
therefore considered to significantly
and demonstratively outweigh the
benefits of the proposal and not to
represent sustainable development
development plan policy hb1 requires
that this proposal should protect the
character and appearance of the
buildings of agricult
architectural or historical interest
this application does not protect
orchard farm i would ask you to vote in
favor of the office's recommendation and
reject this application uh thank you
susie morley
council mansell
are we about to start debate yes
uh does anyone have any questions of
what you've just said can i start the
debate
so i'm now going to move this to debate
are there any members that wish to start
the debate
councilor mansell thank you thank you
chair um i i am
i'd just like to disagree slightly with
councillor password because it's not
that unusual that we don't have an
indicative layout in an outline planning
application we've seen several of them
um however given the history of this
particular site
um
and the fact that uh um several or more
than one at least um reserve mata's
application has been refused i would
have thought it was in the applicant's
interest to have shown us what he was
intending roughly because clearly there
is an issue with the proximity of the
listed building that the red line area
goes to almost adjacent to the enlisted
building
we've already refused other reserve
matters applications because they've got
a large
buildings in proximity to the listed
building but so anyway despite the fact
these things do happen we don't get an
indicative layout but i would have
thought it might be in his interest to
show that he was going to put something
small and
and pleasing in there but it clearly
isn't i'm quite happy to go along with
the officer recommendation uh for
refusal on this site um and for the
reasons listed in the
officer report i'm sorry if i'm going to
disappoint um
councillor matheson but i'm going to
make a proposal uh right now that we um
go along with the office of
recommendation
thank you we do have a proposal club a
second please counsel the field
i'm happy to second that
thank you we will continue a debate
councillor passmore
right thank you barry well i can't
remember when there was last an outline
application like this but it doesn't
matter i actually agree with what has
been proposed and i find it
strange that there was no
pre-application advice i think there is
a degree of uh
it's a very unfortunate attitude let me
put it in a polite way that applicants
put in something very minor history
without taking advice that's at best
very unhelpful
so the lack of detail and i mean if you
look at the top i think it's page 140 um
the report from the uh heritage people
um with insufficient information there
to really judge the effect on the
heritage building to me that's more than
enough reason to go along with the
officer recommendations so i should be
voting for refusal thank you very much
chairman
anybody else
that's nice and quick um it's a place
i'd like to live actually put some
ballots on it i'd quite like to live
there
um when i look at orchard farmhouse if i
lived there i wouldn't like that i
wouldn't like me living behind them uh
not because the houses but for other
reasons so it's a great i think it would
be a lovely place to live but not at any
cost and the cost is the harm that's
given us that historical building
to us to our heritage assets within
suffolk it's wrong as well and
sustainability reasons so i'll be going
along with you and i am going to vote
towards refusal if there's nobody else
that wants to speak
i will ask the governance officer to
move to electronic vote
thank you chair
members that vote is now in progress in
your app
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for refusal
thank you carried and uh
agenda point nine site inspections
for any request
okay thank you
and uh governor's office to report
you've done that therefore uh i will now
formally close the meeting it's just
gone 20 past 12. thank you for your
attendance it's very very valuable and i
think we've all learned something and we
obviously need to get that answer back
to cancer matherson so we can all learn
from his point thank you i've got the i
have actually got the answer the answer
is ten dwellings or more we consult them
we consult the um sustainability officer
and environmental health at ten
dwellings or more
so i
yeah good that's useful to know um
councilman points i i i'm not sure if
the meeting's finished or not um i'm not
sure if you just went up a minute ago i
was just going to ask what is the
protocol for arranging the site visit uh
that was proposed what when will we hear
when it is so we have clue we formally
closed the meeting but um you know we
can answer that question
please john
um i'm gonna have to come away and and
find a date for that for two reasons one
because i might not be around anyway
myself
and second i would like to have the
opportunity to speak to the applicant
and agent
about what has occurred in order for
them to
see very well consider what their next
actions might be
uh but we will obviously need to
organize that visit prior to this
returning to this meeting
but we will have to inform members
separately
alex
okay everybody stay safe and see in the
next meeting
you